what do you say to a more your tiles
while we tossed out some cars oh why not
I'm Callie reading for freelancer
Alessandra Barbosa with The Witcher
trilogy developers CD Projekt RED
established that it's capable of making
compelling role-playing games with tough
decisions Hardy combat and engrossing
lore enthrone breaker The Witcher tales
all but one of these aspects has
persisted this prequel serves up a
captivating tale filled with
gut-wrenching decisions that have
far-reaching consequences the only
difference is that instead of fighting
with a sword you battle with cards
thrown breaker is an intelligence been
on Gwent and manages to transform its
simple premise into an enthralling tale
of family loyalty and hardship as her
men prepared to march Nev climbed the
manors tower smoke rose in columns in
the distance and as more black pillars
appeared one after the other she knew
they meant another hole another barn
another mill was in flames tears welled
in her eyes yet they were tears of anger
bastards if it's war they seek it's war
I shall breathe
reynad prepare to write you play as
queen me ruler of Leiria and Rivia on
the eve of the great nilfgaardian
invasion these ruthless Imperials sweep
across the land like a plague decimating
villages in its citizens hole and
wrestling away control of kingdoms from
their rulers even her company get caught
in the middle dealing with traders
around every corner and spies looking in
the shadows you'll have to make
difficult decisions about who to ally
with in this unpredictable climate as
you rally together a guerilla army to
snuff out the invasion throne breakers
tale involves an entirely new voiced
cast of characters and surprising cameos
throughout its 25 hour campaign its
writing is exceptionally strong bringing
each character's motivations and
principles to life sir Owen breaker also
gives you a room to roleplay with a
familiar gray brush painting your
choices with moral ambiguity leading a
dwindling army into battles with
impossible odds puts an incredible
amount of responsibility on your
shoulders and choose any one to be
empathetic and when to be ruthless has
some fascinating repercussions your
excuses I cannot accept said the Queen
the Vipers who called for the slaughter
they will hang the rest majesty a
townsman fell to leaves feet mercy
please to words taken wrong a
misunderstanding a misunderstanding to
Donnan of escape pay out insufficient
change these are misunderstandings what
happened here was criminal and you'll be
punished as criminals you command me
through multiple large open areas each
bearing a distinctive visual aesthetic
and characters to interact with each
area plays host to the many story
battles you'll need to undertake to
progress but also numerous side missions
and collectible content side quests can
be as simple as making decisions to
solve petty quarrels or as involved as
hunting down dragons and dark caverns at
the request of terrified villagers each
with its own story to tell and rewards
to reap throne breakers world feels
incredibly reactive to your choices
compelling you to take care with how you
handle them you'll also need to gather
resources to better establish your
fighting force and construct new
structures to help build your Gwent deck
throne breaker doesn't make you feel the
need to scour each corner of the map for
resources and usually gives you enough
on its critical path but seeing your
small army grow with each passing area
is rewarding as are the effects it has
on your abilities to fight with your
chosen cards
went and thrown breaker is now a vastly
different game but maintains its core
tenants each card has a power attribute
which is added to a total score and
around is decided by the player with the
highest score once both players have
passed you'll have to carefully weigh
when to go all-in on around or fold
maintaining the strategic element that
Gwent always had but it feels much
faster and throw and breaker with even
more complex combinations to grasp units
have different abilities that could be
triggered in a variety of ways many of
which can be chained up to create
devastating combos each will prove
useful when taking on thrown breakers
shifting rule sets which help the
frequent matches from wearing thin the
way thrown breaker contextualizes its
battles within each grunt game is clever
always fitting the purpose of the story
in some way which helps avoid the
potentially deflating transition between
its story in a simple game of cards even
with these unique rules thrown breakers
main battles can sometimes feel too easy
for their own good this is thankfully
offset by great optional puzzle
encounters giving you a specific deck to
work with and uniquely tailored
challenges these encounters are the best
learning tools thrown breaker has to
offer exposing you to incredibly complex
card combinations as a requirement to
win often these challenges lead to card
unlocks for quints online components so
you're encouraged to take them up as
often as they present themselves babalu
studio of your games don't be tricked
into thinking throne breaker is simply a
lengthy Gwent tutorial its tail is
mandatory if you're looking for more
Witcher lore to chew on accented with
well written characters and a suitably
dark plot that challenges your morals
it also interweaves Gwent into its story
in smart ways that keep it from feeling
like an intrusive method for resolving
combat situations while also helping you
learn its new intricate systems when
twas a site attraction in The Witcher 3
but through throne breaker it's
blossomed into something new that stands
on its own as a proud member of The
Witcher family
[Music]
you